hello and welcome to this video
it's a tournament video again it was fun
on
sunday do another one and um before i
start
just want to again remind you of the
black friday sale it's actually a little
bit of an
unlucky time to do that video because in
a couple of minutes
they will change on chessable the course
is on sale there will be other ones on
sale
i think lifetime nimzo and the karana
repertoire so check it out um chestable
has those
black friday sales up to i think the
sunday something like that so make sure
to check it out and
the other one that's important is the
following
that is that's wrong what i'm doing here
let me go there
simon williams i'm on a stream simon's
stream
today so it's this one yeah you see my
name here
i'm going to be today on tuesday the
24th
on the live stream started here by
ginger gm um about this killing
open champion chess to a tournament so
check it out
i'll be on from that is like six six in
the evening central european time
um and it's the twitch channel yeah
gender gm's
twitch channel i will put it um
twitch.tv gender gm i will put it in the
description so
make sure to check it out now let's go
to the tournament
i'm going to join the hourly blitz
and um here we go does that look okay oh
i guess so
do we see everything that's that's the
thing
is that right
let me check it
it looks somewhat okay
you see the board there's a bit of a bit
much of black
stuff going on but it's it's okay i mean
black stuff means
yeah unused squeal
screen real estate oh i should have
played something a bit more aggressive
against the 1400
i mean that's not a bad opening but it's
not going to win quickly
i berserked as i usually do in a five
minute tournament
i think it's as long as you're
a bit of a favorite in the in the
tournament
it's um a positive
strategy or it's a positive strategy
sounds wrong it's an effective strategy
that should
net you a lot of points positive
strategy is kind of a
weird way to put it yeah here i'm just
developing and playing for the central
breakthrough with e5
i should have played probably some e4
open position and go for a quicker kill
against 1400 here i'm a little bit
surprised
that he's like seven seed
i got some messages in the background i
hope you're not too irritated
so i covered c4 and the general plan is
this one get rid of his defender
the defending bishop i
also have to um keep f4 in mind because
his knight on e5 is short of squares it
only has g4 can make a pre-move here
so let's take and h3 and now i'm not
sure what's best here
f4 is also pretty good
just player 4 immediately i'm not going
to trap the knight he's always able it
goes there okay
so i can push e5 there's nothing wrong
about it
and knight g4 e6 will win material that
would be nice
he probably has to go to g8 or e8
yeah this this looks very
unhealthy
so how do we do this probably something
like this is the best
he might play queen g4 for queen trade
but
i could have taken on f7 already that
would have been better
but okay getting more pieces
into the attack cannot be bad
let's go look h4 threatening mate
and there's also h6 e6 stuff like that
black is completely overloaded
yeah i can i can take on g6 actually
if i like but this is also strong
just attack the queen again and it
doesn't have a good square it has to
just go
um back all the way
d8 or c7 i can take this next
i mean queen takes g6 can be pretty
strong oops it gives me the queen
i mean not that he had anything great
okay now i am not really
i was a bit late and that that game took
a while
but i got the three points that's the
way to go to do it
all right
my typical sicilian
i've got a c3 i'm pretty much always
playing a sicilian nowadays
uh try to get my dirty harry on the
board
it's uh it's very very
fun to get it but get many
anti-sicilians here like the
c3 sicilian this is a very nice position
though
white has completely ruined his pawn
structure here with the double pawn
and i have those ideas to simply pile up
on the
on the d4 pawn that can be difficult to
keep in the long run actually
now bishop b5 i don't know white should
not give up that bishop
yeah but he does this there's a there's
multiple problems there one is that the
bishop can be potentially just strong on
d3 but
now i also have f5 and usually this
square
is not as stable as the bishop on d3 or
h3 would be able to take the knight and
now
the knight on f5 is as solid as a rock
there it cannot be challenged
knight e2 g3 possible but
i mean that is not a terrible thing to
happen and here i'm
happily grabbing a central pawn and
another one
and another one and knight comes back to
c6
and will shield or
shield said the right words probably not
make sure that nothing bad happens on
the c file
okay and b6 i think
that was the plan king d7 next
and now the knight has no squares here
that is a
that is a thing can go to b form
but
okay let's jump in
we'll probably trade on c8 but i'm three
pawns up i think
now the knight still is a little bit
short of squares
so check and then i can try to maybe
trap it
there's also oh let's
go for the knight trap
okay so he's
i have to be a little bit cautious
actually
like nay rook c7 if he would somehow
get here i cannot paint that here or
here i'm close to made so
it's something that should be kept in
mind
it's always a good idea to
i i i don't really do that all the time
and it's costly
what i'm trying to say is think about
possible ways how you could still lose
the game
even though you might have a large
advantage
it's sometimes just good to think about
okay what could possibly go wrong
what are things that could still happen
that make me not win the game or
or draw the game sometimes you just have
to see what's possible but
and this is just sometimes a good
approach to think about okay what could
possibly
go wrong what are scenarios that would
spoil the day
and um well often that helps
finding out those resources for the
opponent
and then you can avoid them and make
sure that nothing bad happens
i'm playing this in a very much don't
rush fashion
because he cannot do anything maybe i
could win quicker in terms of
move count but at least all the moves
that i play are
very simple to play
and that is often also quite important i
know that would blunder
let's just put this ahead
so it's not sometimes a matter of move
count but simply can you play the moves
quickly
like here i will definitely promote now
check and promotion
well
okay so let me check
i'm on first page hopefully six points
yeah
okay
i keep playing my usual stuff
yeah i mean i'm i work hard on those
repertoires on chesapeal and i can i
want to use them
but um sometimes just not winning
quickly yeah
i mean it's all nice like this is
certainly great for me but
i'm not winning the game quickly oh wait
um is there a tactic
no i can't play h3
sometimes like wacky tactics should be
not be overlooked like knight f2 bishop
g3 and so on but everything is covered
so
it's not really a thing okay here i can
take and
this might be a quick win after all
depends on his
willingness to continue in this position
i just win d6 now for
yep for nothing so i get there
getting the first five points on the
scoreboard
there are some other players who have
gone for the stream
the same strategy with berserking all
the games but
they have not yet won the third game
it was a very quick window i mean you
always have to reckon with somebody like
playing five minutes
and they just take ages and then it can
take a while until you get your
i have played d5 here actually normally
that was not what i wanted
yeah this is not fatally bad it's just
like normally i don't allow this
d5
it's a bit slow
he's getting d4 and that's not
exactly what i wanted to have
oh that's very aggressive interesting
okay so let's play like that
it's a very strange uh
configuration could could easily yes
with this move
we could easily get some sort of benoni
i'm not sure if it is any good probably
not
um what about bishop e3
can i play knight f5 in this position
knight f5
takes rookie 8 rook f3
queen e7 is that possible
yeah that's the kind of thing that you
would need at least i
would need a bit of time to make sure
that it actually works but
okay let's
do this
yeah i still wonder about him possibly
playing
f5 um
and i would play i would really love to
play knight f5 here i have no time
that's not a surprise yeah with the
berserk
green d7 is not exactly a dream move
f5 going to be
really dangerous here
okay and i'm going to play this i cannot
stand the idea that he's uh
constantly threatening f5 and e5 and so
on
here he can still play actually e5 maybe
e5 d takes e5 d6 could be it could be
possible
that's actually true
now i'm i'm i'm hugely behind on the
clock
this one i take no i cannot take
so i have to maybe go here
if he takes it knight takes i think it's
perfectly fine
yeah this is fine for me
the problem in this position is the e6
square but
he's not getting there anytime soon and
i'm rather fine here on the light
squares yeah the rook is nice
the position is completely okay
in this configuration he has no chance
of ever using this three against two he
can never make a
pass pawn
pawn takes actually nets me this pawn
already
i think and i have e3 in some cases
but i think i'll just grab it
bishop c3 is that a thing
yeah it is a thing
that was not good that was not good at
all
e3 is probably unwise so play this
now things are have gone a little bit
wrong
they have gone wrong
oops okay
yeah i'm worse and he might
if he goes kingy 2 i probably have to
make that draw this
i have 30 seconds and of course
objectively
shoot that's a good move
nah that went horribly wrong
and that was of course much better
before i
blended the whole thing
if i don't take d5 i'm just much better
structure is already completely ruined
so it's a bit of a shame
that i don't understand what's the point
here
just wants to win some time
maybe
i i have 14 seconds it's the thing
14 seconds
now it's nine
yeah that was very very stupid
white already had outplayed himself
basically
just play something else just not to
grab d5
and bishop c3 is immediately sending me
into that pretty
awful ending
i was not necessary
but okay in the context of the
tournament it's not very relevant i
always just
don't like to lose games that are
pretty much almost in the back or at
least you should never lose them
it's very one-sided already
okay
i have to go into go for quick wins mode
i don't have to do that but i'd like to
in those fast time controls i usually
play just my normal repertoire
like knight f3 c4 stuff but
in the arena format um i'm playing
something
like with a little bit more
drive towards the king going for made is
can be very effective
because winning quickly is is just a
factor
normally it's of course completely
unimportant how fast you win but here it
is important
and this is one of those cases just like
yeah go ahead going
going to kill the black king
it's just much faster than grinding down
like i know some rotten stone wall or
something like that
that once happened to me in arena like
everybody played a stone wall and then
you take like 80 moves to grind them
down
it's hopeless often quickly but you just
take
ages to to actually win
yeah because they continue those rotten
positions till
yeah forever and um
if you your checkmate they cannot
continue it's just just
the beauty of the checkmate okay
now this one
yeah here how do we check mate here i
don't see the mate it's probably just my
complete blindness
many good positions but where is the
chick made
don't see him mate okay
rook h3 sorry rook f3 g3 then
probably wants to trade queens and at
the end i still have to grind an ending
just just stupid stupidly played
okay
queen g8 mate it's not exactly subtle so
he will
defend against it but this is also
checkmate
okay
yeah you get that pretty often that
usually they play bishop f4 the jobarva
london system
bishop g5 is the more traditional way to
play it like
um it was
that like it was intended in this very
soft
opening as it is traditionally called
before jobarva put his uh
yeah um
before jubar got creative with it so to
say
this is nice gives me a tempo for
absolutely nothing
and he cannot take because that wins
the house
and now c4 would have been nice
for bishop b4 win quickly
it doesn't happen now my position here
is fine
it's there's some weaknesses that
i can play against
yeah this is probably a better choice
than taking
as now we can at least put some pressure
here
i won the b6 i'm not sure
it looks a little bit shaky my queen
doesn't have many squares
okay
that feels like it helped the light
squares
are now very weak maybe rook c8
pile up here see going for a cannot play
c4 really i always have knight
b4 not sure what is after here really
knight b3 i'm not sure
i mean it cannot be f4 right that looks
that hits a wall f5 is never happening
f3 okay
now let's let's continue
okay so
i just like to
win c3m i just
that's just enough maybe i could have
taken a2
i was thinking about it yeah because i
really don't see why not
okay one i don't know this is very
simple
i'm just piling up on net weakness and
i just don't see how he defends it he
could have played bishop e1 maybe to
defend it but just like the most passive
way of playing
in the history of chess
so it cannot be all that great
here he has a hard time to defend those
three pawns i will probably win
one of them he can only really make a
choice which one to lose okay so he's he
resigned
yeah that that loss was costlier that uh
mostly because they broke the streak
david vulvar here is uh having five out
of five
and yeah okay let's see if an e4
opening gives better chances of winning
quickly
yeah you can play tons of stuff here
let's play rook g1
the night off like everything has been
tried on move six i think it's
really a bit crazy nowadays they have
tried
every move like yeah even ridiculous
looking stuff oh that's funny
no no interest in facing
facing g4
it looks still a bit harsh
playing for the d5 square
um okay
see preparing long castling maybe
okay why can i not take it because it's
a pin
it's a pin that's stupid
i should have seen that there is a pin
it's not rocket science
okay queen f4 was not what i wanted to
do really
okay so if i castle queenside is he
going to sacrifice there maybe
yep didn't even think about it for a
second
and it could be just good yeah i'm
completely
willing to believe that it's just good
for black
very standard type of sacrifice
yeah d5
bishop a3 is a big problem
i mean not now but the idea check made
me on b2
it's very very much uh
on the cards there are now not anymore
of course the trading queens i thought
would be helpful for me
maybe his position is still okay it's
not
it's not impossible
okay okay let me just stop nigey for
business yeah that was
looking annoying
now i'm also on that
let's grab that pawn
once this is gone then e4 is also weak
okay let's just go back
now that's that's not enough
compensation ever i don't think so
i have g4 also coming
okay that was stopped
i could take f6 here take f6 look here
and not sure about it but i cannot
think forever okay
a rook trait would be immensely helpful
here
not sure that i managed that
tempo that's a good move okay
stopping rookie 7 but
i don't think he can stop everything at
the same time i can also take here
threatening made let's not allow that
there are some ways here to construct a
mating
net i'm wondering about that
i blundered that oops
i wanted to play for the maid
but it was not very intelligent i guess
this check for
oops and then c3 yes
this is a problem
c2 rook c8
i'm really making things very difficult
for myself
and i have ridiculous pieces ridiculous
pieces
oh my i'm not sure this one
it's got to check i have that idea rook
ch8 and then
mate so maybe i i just can checkmate him
here
that's this i don't see it see too i can
play that rook move
it's made check check check
it's got no way is this this this
i'm escaping yeah i think it should win
it was the worst technical play ever
but i think it wins
rook made it's made this one
yeah yeah that's it i cannot really do
anything about it
[Music]
and there's no stalemate it's got too
many pawns
and i was still please don't try that at
home that was really awful
very bad technical play
so what's going on here this this person
wins all the games
that's a lot i should play him
stop his three stop his streak
that would be immensely helpful
um e4 right here try to win quickly
but it can be very tricky because it's
not really my brand of chess
my my core knowledge so the same
this is generally regarded as quite
promising for white here the carrots
attack but
it's it's useful to know stuff and i
don't
i mean i know that you should uh
go ahead with those things quickly now
can you take on e6 here maybe
i mean this is also certainly possible
let's do a g6
maybe knight takes e6 was
was on okay
hmm and now i don't have something
really good that's kind of depressing
oops maybe he plays queen f6
i can play rook f4 it's just a very
a very odd way of trapping the queen
so there are some chances that you might
fall for that it's a bit cheap
it's a bit of a cheap idea
he took took a long time and of course
spotted it
so i can take i can
also check but then knight f6 comes
bishop f4 is a tempo though
that cannot be so bad right
win that tempo if he goes
queen h1 i can maybe just take on
c6 and then take on d6
oh no i didn't blunder my central pawn
okay that was good win quickly
yeah probably here david vuva is doing a
good job there
winning the games but he played two
games less than i did of course it's a
bit lucky if you win
so quickly that position was probably
not even that clear and yeah just
handing me the queen is
of course helping
playing calculus
come on dirty harry no oh man
okay i could have taken on e4 that's
actually a line that i had recommended
in my
my magnus course fight like magnus i
think this is also on sale right
not sure if it is today or if it starts
today if you want to get that
magnus repertoire it's also
in the black friday sale at some point
i'm not sure
maybe later this week
i have a list somewhere but it's always
all the courses are on sale only for 48
hours
so um yeah just just check it out
the page on chester with my author page
if you want to get some of those things
yeah that's not the most exciting
position that i've ever had
and queen c8 was a weird decision can
just take e8
okay i mean that's not a big problem
itself okay it doesn't take it
then that actually works out quite well
then i can
win this half tempo here
yeah he's got a very nice blockading uh
wait i can take care right
locating setup going but now that's a
problem pawn takes
just drops that immediately and bishop
takes
um yeah i can take him
and now this one
just grab stuff
okay now what's what's going on here i
can play
can i take on a2 that's like the
greediest move ever
i don't see why not honestly e8 is very
very safely covered
if he's got a tactic there then it's bad
luck
doesn't seem to be the case but i'm
still scared
i want to make sure i'm not running into
some some stupid background made
queen d3 i'm looking at h7
how do we do that here
and rook a1 maybe coming
queen b8 is not a problem
i think
oh i didn't even think about that move
now queen is dominating
and check here maybe
how is he playing this it's a little bit
odd
king king h2 bishop e5 king h1 queenie
one
uh queen one is actually blundering the
queen i should not do that
but i can go here this is also
pretty good
and now i don't have
i don't have a check on the second rank
life's not fair
queen f1 maybe
threatening on h3 and threatening here
he's got no check right there's nothing
that he can do really
no yeah that wins the house
yes you know move here really
come on please don't yes don't let the
clock run down
check check
check
the any way to
win quickly this one
that one's the queen
i can check here and take c5 i mean
[Music]
everything wins but it was not the
fastest way to do it for sure
oh i have eight seconds i completely
ignored the time
i was just thinking okay this is so
totally over that
didn't pay any attention
i was close i didn't look at the clock
at all
just like what what can possibly happen
yeah you can always lose on time
all right so i'm doing okay
okay this thing didn't berserk this one
oh
there we go it's a not an easy opponent
actually
bishop g4 okay
yeah i have a nice position here just a
very nice central control
and it's not entirely clear what black
is doing
now the center is just pretty nice
in my favor but you still have to make
some progress it's nice to
have the space and everything but it
doesn't mean that you have a clear way
forward
okay let's go here jump
jump to b6 and sometimes knight c5 also
can be on
knight e4 might be a move but i have
queen c2 that's not a thing
okay let's get rid of this one
knight b6
okay
this is dangerous oops not the hey
yeah that's i got that's paint stuff
it's dangerous so check
i can take here but if i
play like that let me check as a little
blop a little bit so if i take e7 knight
g4
takes takes rook h1
yeah it's just good time
should be good
he has to take on g4 what else
i'm threatening a knight f6 mate
basically
the only thing that's not so great is my
knight on a4
it's like it's completely unrelated
currently to the position
if it would be somewhere near the middle
of the board then
things would be more or less over
yeah i was thinking about this this is
an idea
i still don't like the night
it's always a bit odd i think
it was it made sense yeah at the time 94
but
it feels a little bit like it's time to
correct this
okay it's still nice to have the h file
open that could come in handy
a nice one would be like get the knight
here g5 and then
go go to places where it hurts black
knight b697 also would be cute
he wants to go to e6 i guess
that's better stop that
i blended d5 ouch
that was terrible terrible
knight e6 queen f6 that
nice i think unless i'm blundering stuff
i'm threatening this now of course
for the mate
yeah not sure if 96 was helping him so i
take
take this the only thing is i'm not
threatening something immediately i have
won a piece but
i'm not threatening to mate him
maybe this one that is a threat like to
consolidate and just win
yeah that is that is actually a thing
to just
organize things and go for go for the
kill queen e5
knight f6 this is a clean way of doing
it
i didn't see that here that he actually
attacks this
yeah let's stop that
i mean the pin i have to stop the pin
yeah and just queen e5 and knight f6
should do
the job
where's the mate i don't see it as usual
so where is the maid
this one is threatening mate
yeah that was five points
i need five points well this is this
this person is winning all the games
it's really
really strong
david volvo
i shouldn't pre-move knight f6 yeah okay
i thought i hoped for a dirty harry but
of course it did not materialize
people rather go for
the alapin and then they fight for
equality after one move area
okay okay let's grab stuff
i'm not sure that this is best actually
i mean i was
fine with the like not grabbing
but yeah yeah this is a this is a thing
that even could be some compensation
not enough but
[Music]
to the extent where i'm wondering if it
was the best thing to do
what
okay
yeah it's not not at all easy to
do something in this position
i'm not coordinated well obviously
it looks awful anyway i have to
be somewhat fast
now yes obviously a huge compensation
for the pawn here
with a4 a5 coming and he's playing this
well
okay
not sure if that helps him but
i'm did not see this move at all
it's kind of concerning
rook d3 oops
no g4 it's almost made
covering the square
okay i think i'm fine now honestly
it's two pawns and if he's not mating me
i'm i'm just fine
which is true for every chess position
of of course but
the the main concern was getting
checkmated really
not like being a pawn down or something
it was just like oh my he might
checkmate me five
oh nah i still have rook f6 okay nothing
nothing terrible going on i will
probably win on time
he's just not not fast at all
interesting why did he resign
i mean it's probably lost but i still
have to play rook f6
okay i was good winning this it was a
bit of a shaky game
they're here 100 percent for david vova
david i don't know so
it's not a very precise move order
actually
okay so we might might get to a
completely normal
grundfeld and we do we do get them
e4
h6 h6 is a bit uncommon
yeah but we can probably play many moves
to check i mean
we both berserked some
bishop a3 is often an idea here
yeah b6 comes into consideration but i
don't i don't think he has something
great anyway really that looks
completely wrong
opening up everything while you're not
actually developed looks wrong
or yeah not fully developed let's say
okay not certain about all this here
maybe
okay so knight c7 you don't care about
knight c7
no yeah i mean i saw that but
i felt it's not a big issue
here bishop f6 or what's going on
i don't know it's playing quite quickly
so i take it
and maybe this one
okay then i can just win f5 yeah
yeah it takes bishop e5 check
[Music]
it's a problem it's always a problem if
you have a piece down for nothing but he
couldn't
really have he didn't have a any
attractive reply
so let's just keep it as simple as
possible
a minute is plenty though okay
so yeah i'm getting there david vuva oh
it's actually over already
i didn't didn't pay attention to the
tournament clock
i was just like completely zoning in and
playing my games
so that was nice actually i lost this
one game
against mala boom what was that again
ah they are completely i lost track
there yeah i lost track in that game
i think the other games were reasonable
it's fun that i still even with 11 out
of 12
there was no way of um
keeping the rating i mean it's not
important it's like one loss is enough
and let me check i want to check this
game against
malibu um i really played badly because
i think um here
i do agree why can i not do that
why can i not die i can so yeah
here yeah here i felt things were not
doing
things were not right yeah he has a very
strong center and
i was thinking about tactical tricks
like like
this for example can we do this yeah um
like
this for example but i don't think it
works we can switch on the engine
so the idea is that well here it cannot
work but
more like here oh my goodness i'm sorry
about that
like here stuff like
this is interesting i don't think it
works yeah like this
and then play for for those pins but
he's
just fast enough i cannot get enough on
e3 simply it's just a joke of an idea it
doesn't work
and then you're just stuck here
in a in a somewhat passive benoni g4 is
a good
suggestion but i think he played it okay
h4 is not great i think
f5 looks strong it's just strong
the problem is that my knight is totally
wrong i mean if it would be
somehow able to go to e5 and then it's
okay but not like this after h4 f5 i'm
good
because i can block the light squares
and it seems that there is no um
that e5 does not have a decisive effect
i can
take that pawn and here
here i'm okay probably but i didn't play
it right yeah
queen c7 and here
h5 or h5 yeah
yeah i was this this sequence this this
sequence handed everything over to me
and it was it was very favorable now
but this is here
i just i just played it badly f takes is
already a mistake
because my plan was to take on d5 that
was the thing
if i just take with a rook i have all
the advantages because
this is completely devalued you cannot
play g4
and that can sometimes just stop it
entirely and it's just sitting on
weaknesses d5 is weak
and the endings are all bad like a
bishop ending is probably just lost
yeah and the computer gives something
like this
and after all i will win that pawn it
it's just
probably unavoidable in the long run i
just this is a bad
mistake just a bad mistake
and here he rook takes d6 is probably a
lot stronger yes
just playing for the attack playing for
ideas like this
and then the ending is probably equal oh
and that's not equal
yeah why did why it was better here as
well yeah
yeah i mean we didn't have much time so
it's clear that there were some
some blunders but i should definitely
not take
this is already strategically much
better
and easy it's fairly easy to play you
just don't have to worry about anything
king is safe and the queen here is
remaining passive
so that was an interesting game that i
lost i hope you enjoyed the
little tournament a bit of an hour of
some fast some fast chess and if you
actually watch that before my
broadcast with simon starts tuesday
the 24th at 6 cent european time
make sure to tune in will be much fun i
guess okay
thanks for watching